[Musique]
à chacun son étoile c'est le nom de la
comédie musicale de la troupe nymag un
spectacle d'une heure trente monté avec
des enfants du territoire
un mélange de chants théâtre et mise en
scène le but faire rêver les enfants
c'est une envie commune une équipe de
quatre personnes de pouvoir faire
partager notre expérience de la scène du
spectacle à une bande d'enfants
objectif faire découvrir aux chanteurs
en herbe l'avis de professionnels du
spectacle les emmener en studio et donc
ils ont fait leur premier single ont
fait leur premier clip n'a pas écouté
j'arrive donc faire leur première
interview donc c'est génial
la troupe est composée de quatre
professionnels du spectacle
auteur compositeur metteur en scène ou
encore coachs vocaux
ils sont là pour guider les enfants
pendant les répétitions
moi je suis là pour leur donner des
petites clés de temps en temps quand je
sens que c'est recevable pour eux mais
je vais pas très loin parce que je veux
simplement qu'ils soient bien ce sont
des enfants je vais pas leur mettre de
pression ou leur donner des outils
techniques trop pointu parce que j'ai
envie qu'ils s'amusent en fait et parmi
les enfants chacun a sa chanson préférée
j'aime beaucoup ma chanson des l'étoile
des mers
avi
à
là
m
j'aime beaucoup le final c'est ma
chanson c'est quand y'a tout le monde
sur scène et qu'on salue tous à la fin
et je trouve séquencé collectif quand on
est tous là c'est les meilleurs
mouvements
l'histoire luna est une petite fille qui
vient d'emménager dans un nouveau
quartier elle fait appel à son étoile
symphonia
à deux elles partent dans un monde
imaginaire à la découverte de
personnages loufoques et attendrissant
un ours une étoile de mer ou encore un
fantôme c'est un peu le plus gentil
fantôme
il est détesté par tout les autres
fantômes et puis va se faire les amis du
coup avec symphonia et luna 7 enfants
ont participé à l'expérience nymag un
projet qui leur a permis de s'affirmer
avant j'arrivais pas du tout à chanter
devant les gens s'étaient même pas
devant mes parents alors que là je
m'apprête à faire un spectacle devant
tous les parents de toute la comédie
musicale et j'ai vraiment pris confiance
en moi une représentation de la comédie
musicale aura lieu le 25 septembre à
versailles